>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Tim Smith: Today I'm with
Mary Roach who is the author
of six books about science.
Her topics have included human
digestion to human cadaver
and humans in outer space.
Her newest book "Grunt" looks at the
curious science of humans at war.
The book includes vintage
Roach, boundless curiosity
and infectious enthusiasm all
written with a delightful sense
of humor and there are of course
lots of maggots throughout the book.
One reviewer likened her to
the perfect dinner guest,
rolling out one surprising
story after another and I found
that to be very true reading this
one and reading her previous books.
"Grunt" isn't a look at the
ballistics of war or the raw power
of nuclear bombs, what you might
think of as military science.
Her book, like all her other
books is a study primarily
of the human body and
she says I'm interested
in the parts no one
makes movies about,
not the killing but
the keeping alive.
Mary, thanks for being
with us today.
>> Mary Roach: Oh,
thank you, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Tim Smith: So, as I've said
you've written about space and sex
and the human body and why
the science of humans at war?
>> Mary Roach: Well, it's a
topic that I got interested
in in kind of an unusual way.
I was reporting a Smithsonian
magazine piece
on the world's hottest
chili peppers.
I was in India and while I was there
somebody said oh the Indian Defence
Ministry took these chili peppers
and made a non-lethal weapon,
kind of an, essentially a pepper
spray but in a powdered bomb that.
And I thought well I need
to report on that so I went
over to the Indian
Defence Ministry's lab
and I spent a day kind
of poking around as I do
and they were working on that.
They had been working on a leech
repellant which fascinated me
and I thought that at
that point I just realized
that military science is a
little broader and more esoteric
than I had thought and
it just planted a seed
that this might be a sort of
Roachable territory as it were.
And got and then I got home.
There was a, I happened
to be corresponding
with a retired army pathologist
who had, I think he read "Stiff",
I'm guessing and I said you
know I'm sort of thinking
about military science but I
think access would be a problem.
What do you think?
And he said I think you should try
it and he introduced me to people
at the Armed Forces Medical
Examiner System at Walter Reed
and he really sort of opened
some doors and encouraged me
to run with it which I did.
>> Tim Smith: And was the
military pretty responsive
in having you poke around?
>> Mary Roach: They were
surprisingly receptive to it.
You know it was, a lot of
times, it took a year to get.
I spent some time on a ballistic
missile submarine out at sea.
That took about a year to set up
not because people were saying no,
but because nobody knew who's
the person to say 'yes'.
So it would be like
you'd start with a,
you know you'd have
the submarine group
and then the naval operations
person and the, you know
and then I would get approval
all the way up at the top.
And then we had to find who wants to
be the submarine captain that goes,
yeah, yeah she can
come on my boat now.
So, that took some doing
so, but people were.
People had been.
The Department of Defence
were, I think they were.
Yeah, these are stories
that don't get told
and they're positive stories.
They're stories about
scientists who are trying
to make this very difficult
experience of serving
in the military in combat, trying
to make it a little
more bearable and safer.
So it's a story that I think
they were happy to tell
so it was surprisingly, they
were very helpful in fact.
They didn't, yeah they didn't have
a chance to vet the manuscript.
It wasn't that sort of
like, well we'll let you in
but in return we have
to see the manuscript.
They were, they had no real input.
They didn't really know
what I was doing except
in a very general sense.
>> Tim Smith: So what is the, one
of the interesting things I learned
in the book is it's not just
about keeping a soldier alive
but it's also ensuring that they
have a decent quality of life
if they have an injury
or what have you.
And if I can just read,
just two sentences.
"The long-term quality of a soldier
or a marine's life is a
relatively new consideration.
In the past, military
decision-makers have concerned
themselves more with go, no-go.
Do the injuries keep a soldier
from contemplating permission?
Have we lost another
pawn in the game?"
Do you have any examples
of ways that they're trying
to improve the life of a soldier?
>> Mary Roach: Well, the whole
book is, I mean there's everything,
you know everything from you
know heat injury and heat stroke
which in recent conflicts has
been a big issue to diarrhea
which people tend to think well
that's kind of tee-hee topic.
Historically speaking, I mean this
was, you know you look at conflicts
like the Mexican War of 1848,
seven deaths from dysentery
and disease to one combat death.
In recent years with improvements
in sanitation you don't have the
same situation where there was
like sort of a mess tent set up
right next to a field latrine
and flies going back and
forth and no refrigeration
and you know hundreds of
troops getting sick with things
like typhoid fever and dysentery
and dying so now we don't have that.
But we still, in like the Special
Operations Forces who are still
out in remote areas eating, you
know they're not on the base
where it's very sanitized
so there's a very,
very high food poisoning rates
so, just all manner of things
that you don't necessarily
think about as risks of combat.
These are the things that you
know I look at in the book.
>> Tim Smith: And you said at some
point in the book that the cost
of I guess combating food poisoning
could be as much as the cost
of combating Post Traumatic
Stress Disorder.
>> Mary Roach: Well, no as they
were talking about something,
it's called their post-infectious
consequences
of severe food poisoning,
irritable bowel
and there's something called
reactive arthritis so, that you can,
you have a five-fold greater
increase of developing
if you've had a severe
case of food poisoning.
So, and that's a, you know the
VA will cover benefits for that.
So the diarrhea person, the
diarrhea expert that I spoke
to his feeling was that that could
rival in expenditures what is spent
on PTSD so it is, you know
definitely [inaudible] the bigger
problem and not one that sort of is
obvious to people when they think
about serving in the military.
>> Tim Smith: And am I
correct in recalling that,
and if I am this is a
real eye-opening fact,
when I read the book that a
cholera patient could discharge
like what is it, five
gallons of fluids?
>> Mary Roach: Yeah, that's
the statistic that I heard.
I mean so much so that there's a
navy Captain Philips [phonetic]
who I forget which
year exactly but one
of his contributions among
others was the invention
of something called the
cholera cot which is a cot
with a hole right here and
a bucket just because it,
just that you can't keep
changing the beds quickly enough.
It's a, and that's
why it's so fatal,
you just dehydrate
so quickly so yeah.
>> Tim Smith: And let's
get to the maggots.
I know I brought it up
in the introduction.
They found that interestingly that a
maggot can be used to clean a wound.
>> Mary Roach: Yeah, this
was a World War I discovery.
There was a, surgeon with the
French Expeditionary Forces
who was seeing patients.
A few patients had come in who had
been out in the bush for a few,
in the field for a few days,
coming in with big wounds
that had been infested with maggots.
And of course the natural
response is to get those
out of there you know fear that
they're going to promote infection.
And what Dr. Baer kept seeing
over and over in these patients,
in these soldiers was that when they
took away the maggots there was this
fresh, pink healthy tissue coming
in and there was no infection
which was, ran counter
to what one would expect.
And he noticed this over and over.
In fact ten years later in
civilian life decided to try
that with some cases of stubborn
infections that weren't responding
to normal treatment and
in fact they do work well
because what a maggot does is it's,
it just performs a
natural debridement
that that debridement is taking
away the dead tissue to encourage,
to [inaudible] infection and
encourage the growth of new tissue.
So that, maggots as we all
know like, they like dead stuff
so by putting them in there.
And you have to, there's a
dosage for maggot therapy.
Maggot therapy is still done today.
There's a, you'll need
a prescription.
>> Tim Smith: It has a
Medicare billing code.
>> Mary Roach: Yes, there's
a Medicare reimbursement code
and a dosage and they put
something called a cage dressing.
So you have this little community
there on your leg or your foot.
It's often in diabetic
patients with foot ulcers.
They're difficult to treat.
So, and you would think that it's
a very disturbing, upsetting thing
to have maggots feeding upon you in
any capacity but in fact if you have
that kind of infection
that is not going away
and here's a possible treatment
you welcome it to the point,
to the extent that some of the
folks who have been patients
of maggot therapy,
there are t-shirts.
The company Medical Maggots
has t-shirts that say 'Maggots
on Board' [laughter] so people
kind of proclaim to the world
and in fact they kind of get
involved in this little community.
And they're not, because they're.
When you put them in
they're kind of the size
of a cupcake sprinkle, they're tiny.
They're not the big, fat kind
of squirmy Halloween
horror story maggots
that we're used to envisioning.
They're small and they all come in.
They go head-down into the wound,
actually immerse themselves and feed
in that way so that just
their butts are sticking.
They actually breathe
through their ass [laughter].
Among the maggots' many charms,
it's an ass-breather
so they're all kind of.
Just their little butts
are sticking up.
It kind of looks, it reminded me
of on an accordion all the array
of buttons, just like these
little kind of squirmy buttons.
So it isn't quite.
I envisioned this like sort
of like, the thing you see
in a gross-out movie but it's
not really like that, anyway.
>> Tim Smith: I told you, this is
like our favorite part of Mary.
So what happens if one of these
maggots inadvertently turns
into a fly?
I mean it wouldn't be inadvertent.
It's its natural course
but [multiple speakers].
>> Mary Roach: Ah, that is why.
That's one of the reasons it's
been a bit of an uphill battle
for advocates of maggot therapy,
you know trying to introduce.
What is the maggot sign?
>> Tim Smith: [Laughter] that's
the maggot sign [laughter].
>> Mary Roach: [Laughter]
thank you [laughter].
The, yeah because when a maggot,
a maggot is just a feeding machine
and it wants to eat enough
to prepare itself to go off
for its very sci-fi
journey where it's going
to off, pupate and become a fly.
So, you want to.
You have to remove them
after a couple of days
because you don't want them
leaving, trying to leave the wound
and go pupate because then you
have flies in your hospital
and that's the last
thing that you want.
So, it's a. Maggot therapy,
maggots are cheap but the,
you need nursing staff to change
them, to change the cage dressing,
to make sure they're not
left in too long to the point
where they're all trying
to go off and hide
and pupate and become flies, yeah.
>> Tim Smith: And you I guess in the
course of your research had looked
at the Office of Strategic
Service, was looking at using flies
as a weapon of war in
Southern Morocco was it?
>> Mary Roach: Yeah, yeah if the OSS
which was the precursor to the CIA,
Stanley Lovell who is
the head of research,
an imaginative fellow had this idea
that, because they were trying to.
This was in North Africa, they were.
There was this region,
Spanish Morocco it was called
and they were trying to stop
the Nazis from heading in
and cutting off a supply line.
Anyway they his idea was to create a
simulated, there were a lot of goats
in the area so create
simulated goat dung
that would be spiked with pathogens.
The flies would then land
on the simulated goat dung,
pick up the pathogens and go land on
the Nazis' food, inoculate the food
or the Nazis directly
with these pathogens
and thereby covertly destroy these
groups of Nazis who were there.
So that was the idea.
It was called 'Operation
Capricious', it never,
sort of a play on Capricorn, goat.
>> Tim Smith: Oh, right,
right [inaudible].
>> Mary Roach: A little
obscure, so, it never.
It was. They never
deployed the special dung
and oh, this was the best part.
They were going to drop the dung
from airplanes in the
middle of night.
And he said in his memoir, I
figured there's so much dung
around no one would really notice.
I think you'd notice when
someone is dropping goat dung
in the middle of the night.
I think that's not normal.
>> Tim Smith: If it
falls on your tent.
>> Mary Roach: Yes, so, yeah.
Anyway but it was an idea that was.
That's as far as it went.
I think it was just a bad.
It went as, about as far
as a cocktail napkin, yeah.
>> Tim Smith: But looking
through the dung
and the flies you did find
a product called Who Me?
>> Mary Roach: Who Me?
Yeah, this was another
fanciful Stanley Lovell idea
and this one was actually,
two years were spent on this.
This is again World War
II and it was an idea
that Lovell stole from the Brits.
The Brits had something
called Stench Liquid.
What this was, it was meant to be a
cheap, small, covertly-deployed tube
or atomizer of hideous stink
and this would be distributed
to motivated citizens who,
your saboteurs who would then,
when they spotted Japanese or Nazi
officers, sidle up and deploy this
and it was treated like a weapon.
There was like the, it was supposed
to have a range of ten feet.
There could be no backfire
obviously.
The British one actually had a
compound that would delay the onset
of the stench so that the operator
could disappear before the stench
hit so it was a lot of thinking,
two years of work and some big,
fat files in the OSS
archives were dedicated
to this SAC23 was the
technical term.
Who Me? Was the nickname
that Stanley Lovell gave it.
The idea being it was
supposed to just smell like,
this is his words not Mary Roach's,
a very loose bowel movement.
So, the idea was to humiliate,
destroy morale and you know just by,
you know just every little bit
helps in these war efforts.
So thus began this highly
entertaining to me anyway,
back and forth of letters between
the Arthur Little Chemical Company
who were trying to come up with an
odor that was not only repellent
but universally, in all cultures,
would be considered repellent
and just a little bit weird
so that it was unidentifiable.
They wanted it in like a mix, not
entirely the loose [inaudible]
but something added to it so that it
would be scary as well as hideous.
So, that's what you
want with a malodorant
and those are still
things that yeah,
more recently the military
has funded you know
into crowd dispersal
that kind of thing.
So you want it to be
foreign smelling
so somebody says I don't know what
that is and it's freaking me out.
I'm going to leave.
So it's got to be not only foul
but a little bit confusing,
unidentifiable and
scary so there is.
So, they went back and forth
and then the testing began
and they were testing it
like in tropical conditions
and Arctic conditions.
And it had to be you
know the tubes would have
to withstand a certain
amount of drop force.
And then they would be delivered to
the people who were testing them.
And they'd show up and half of them
were leaking and then they had,
they had a lot of problems with
blowback and backfire [laughter]
and dribble so a lot of
angry letters back and forth
between the people who had, you know
commissioned these both the state
and the deployment system.
And in the end, Who Me?, they
produced a whole batch of it
and then 17 days later after the
final, final report on Who Me?
The first bomb was dropped on
the Japanese so they never.
So the stink bomb never
was deployed.
>> Tim Smith: But they also
found that like a stench
or a smell is not universal
and that it can also hinge
on the environment and?
>> Mary Roach: Yeah, that's right.
I mean if you take butyric acid
is, if you smell it in a deli,
you know a cheese shop it's part.
You sniff a piece of
Parmesan cheese,
that is, that's butyric acid.
It's also, it's vomit, the
smell of vomit so depending
on the context it's you know it's
kind of a pleasant cheesy smell
or it's an unpleasant vomit smell.
And the Monell Chemical
Senses Center
who has done some work more
recently for the military
on malodorants you know
for dispersing a mob
or clearing a space, a
compound or whatever,
they in the 1990s travelled
around with this woman Pam Dalton,
travelled around and in her
suitcase she had little bottles.
She had vomit, sewage, burnt hair
and U.S. government
standard bathroom malodor.
And she, which was
in fact the winner,
this being a compound
developed in World War II
for testing latrine deodorants.
You need to standardize
hideous latrine smell
against which you'd try out your
latrine deodorants so this compound,
this was the winner
internationally, globally,
culturally because she would
take these odors around
and just presenting them
to people out of context.
Something like 3% of
Caucasians found vomit
to be a wearable scent
like [inaudible].
Sewage in many cultures, there
was a percentage of people
who thought yeah, that's edible.
I would eat that so the U.S.
government standard bathroom malodor
was the winner.
What was interesting is
that once you had that,
that universally offensive and
hideous smell the subtly here which,
this was why you need the pros at
the Monell Chemical Senses Center.
They added a fruity,
floral top note,
the top note being the first thing
you get so when you're exposed
to a new smell you are tentative.
You take a little whiff and
that's, that was the fruity,
floral and then you're
encouraged because that's pleasant
to take a big keeper, inhale.
So, on the keeper inhale
you would get this onslaught
of this hideous smell.
So that whole package is known
as stench soup and that is.
I don't know where
stench soup was deployed
and neither does Pam Dalton.
She said I gave them the formula.
I don't know what they did with it.
It's somewhere out there
probably somebody's got a supply
of stench soup.
I myself had some that sat in my
closet in a little vial for a long,
long time with, you know
encased in activated charcoal.
And I finally got the courage
on the book tour to open it up
and there was a lot of fanfare
like I'm going to open this up.
It was at a big event
and I was going to,
I thought of taking
it, no never mind.
>> Tim Smith: Let's throw
some out here [laughter].
>> Mary Roach: [Laughter] so but
all of the scent had been absorbed
into the activated carbon and so it
was this large anticlimactic moment
but I did smell some
at Monell and it is.
You do not open that without the
fume hood, under the fume hood
with the fans going and that's.
It's pretty bad.
>> Tim Smith: So, I guess one.
>> Mary Roach: I should
have brought some.
Can you?
>> Tim Smith: Well,
aren't you curious now?
>> Mary Roach: [Inaudible] spritz.
>> Tim Smith: So, one of the
most life-changing injuries
that you've discussed in the
book are injuries to the penis.
>> Mary Roach: Yes.
>> Tim Smith: And the male genitals.
And this is, I guess it was kind
of an awkward subject
for a lot of people.
>> Mary Roach: Yes.
>> Tim Smith: I'm sure it was
awkward for the military as well
but what are some of
the improvements
that they're making there?
>> Mary Roach: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, urogenital trauma is the
more technical term and it's become
in recent conflicts, it's become
more of a problem for two reasons.
One, the size of the bombs, the
IEDs, they're bigger so it's not
like you know a land mine you
would tend to you know lost a limb,
maybe to here, maybe here.
And now these are bigger explosions
going up to the pelvic region.
And the other thing
that's happened is
that medical emergency trauma care
in the field has become better
and faster so more men are
surviving to have these injuries
to the groin area, the penis.
And so the surgical, I was at
Walter Reed where there was,
they were repairing the urethra
of a young man who'd had,
who had sustained such an injury.
And it was fascinating in that, you
know I came into the operating room
and you know they put the blankets,
you know the drapes I guess
they're called, surgical drapes,
and normally you know
they just leave the part
that they're working
on, and oddly they were
up at his face which I thought odd.
And but what they were doing, they
take a rectangle of the inside
of the cheek because that's,
first of all it's hairless.
And for a urethra you
don't want there to be hair
because minerals cans collect on the
hair and you can end up with stones
and so you don't want hair.
And you also want tissue
that is going to be able
to withstand a moist environment
and the inside of the cheek is that.
So, they took a little rectangle
and they would roll it into a tube
and use it basically to patch
the urethra, and in that way,
he would still be able to pee
through his penis, rather than,
because if you can't do that they
thread it through the perineum.
It's a word I've often.
>> Tim Smith: Read but
not heard [laughter].
>> Mary Roach: Yes,
read but not heard.
Anyway the [inaudible] I believe
the [inaudible] is [inaudible].
The more casual term,
anyway they would have
to thread the urethra and you would.
Then he would have to sit
down over the toilet to pee.
And I had this conversation
in the operating room
with a surgeon, the
assisting surgeon.
The assisting surgeon was a woman.
The surgeon was a man.
And I said, you know how big a deal
is that to have to pee you know
through the perineum and he
said, the surgeon said well,
given all of the other challenges
of losing a limb et cetera
and I don't think it's
that big a deal.
And the woman turned to me, the
assisting surgeon said it's huge.
So, you know and so the
surgery was you know,
it did what it was supposed
to do and he's now able
to urinate normally and while I
was there the surgeon happened
to mention something going on at
Johns Hopkins which, I mean this was
about two years ago, I hadn't
heard about that they were.
He said over at Johns Hopkins
right now there's a surgeon,
they're doing what's called a wet
run which is using cadavers to work
out the logistics of
a penis transplant.
And the first penis transplant
was a few months ago and that was
at Mass General, not Johns
Hopkins but I was able to see
and it was just fascinating.
It was, you know they had two,
two bodies you know the recipient
and the donor and one circumcised
and one not which was interesting.
They're dead, it doesn't
matter but anyway just to,
you know and they had it.
They had this set up where they
had a, you know an IV and a bag
of dyed saline, dyed blue and you
could you know turn the stopcock
and they had hooked it
up to a certain artery
and they could then see what
region was profused by this artery
and that would tell them you know,
is a critical artery to reattach?
Is this you know an important
one and how material do we take?
And you don't just lop
it off like a tree.
I mean you have to take the roots.
You've got to take, sorry anyway.
I don't even remember
what your question was.
>> Tim Smith: This was two chapters.
>> Mary Roach: Oh, but I was going
to say you had asked me what sorts
of things are being done.
And one of the things I found
interesting was that the,
some of the surgical techniques, the
reconstruction, not transplantation
and not just repairing a urethra
but reconstruction, some of that is
in you know in collaboration
between military surgeons
and transgender surgeons so
you know you don't often sort
of imagine the military and the
transgender sort of community like.
I don't know, getting together
and helping each other,
it was lovely, lovely.
>> Tim Smith: So, one
more question on this
and then I'll move to underwear.
Actually I think I just
forgot my question.
So we'll move on to underwear.
Why are silk underwear the best
underwear to wear in a war zone?
>> Mary Roach: Well, silk
is surprisingly strong.
It's very lightweight and strong
and so it's, it's used to.
It's not going to be
bulletproof but in terms of.
I mean people think of Kavala.
They think just that Kavala, you
could make a pair of underpants
that would be bulletproof.
Like you'd need like 15 to 40 plies
to be actually, yeah it's not going
to be a comfortable
pair of underpants.
So, silk is, silk is almost
as protective I mean in terms
of just you know a light layer.
And it's not protecting
against a bomb or a gunshot
but what it's protecting you
against if there's an IED
explosion you know the tremendous,
because these are buried bombs
so they are launching
at very high speed.
Dirt, sand, debris
and a lot of pathogens
and what happens when an IED.
You step on an IED or very near an
IED the tissue kind of blows out
and the debris blow goes in
and then the tissue comes back
and you can have, just have
horrendous recurring infection.
So, underwear or what you
know not necessarily just
for underwear but that's.
It's very good whether it's
silk or a few plies of Kavala,
it's keeping that material
from penetrating.
So, there isn't any,
you used to read.
There was a time when one
of these companies was sort
of marketing bomb-proof underwear
which you know is the guy
at Natick Labs where
they work on underwear,
he said you know if
they can develop.
If the surgeons can make a bomb
that will flip a mine-resistant arm
and personnel carrier they can
certainly make a bomb that's going
to blow up your underwear.
So, it's not bomb-proof
but it does help a lot
in preventing infection yeah.
>> Tim Smith: And when
you're a combat medic you're
in a real high-stress situation
and I mean a lot of us,
our instincts are not
like focused on one thing
and you observed medics
getting trained?
>> Mary Roach: Yes, yeah, yeah
the challenge like you mentioned.
If you're in a [inaudible]
area where there's loud noises
and people shooting, whether
they're shooting at you or not,
it's a. You have a burst
of adrenalin and a fight
or flight response and what
that does is it makes you fast,
strong and dumb is the
way they describe it.
It makes you able to run
away, throw a big rock,
whatever you know just
sort of brute strength.
It does not help you focus,
make good cognitive choices,
operate delicate machinery
or cut an airway in somebody
who is struggling to breathe.
What it does for you, the opposite
of what you need so combat medics
and Navy corpsmen who provide
medical care for the Marine Corps,
they're trained at places
like strategic operations
which is this old movie studio,
a big movie studio
near Camp Pendleton.
The guy who owns it used to do
action movies and war movies
so he's got a lot of technology
for loud noises, pyrotechnics
and he employs actors
to play injured people
including amputee actors.
The day I was there, there was this
amputee who had a sleeve over the,
his leg and it had been very
artfully designed with gore
and it had a backpack
with just the right amount
of stage blood and a pump.
It would pump so he could and
he could control the bleed
in a realistic way and depending
on how the medic applied the
tourniquet could either be saved
or die.
And he was acting that role along
with it and screaming and making,
you know making things as stressful
as possible for this young man
so that he could practise doing
care in a stressful environment.
And the hope being if you do it
a few times in a safe environment
and learn to cope with that
and maintain your focus,
hopefully you'll be
a little better off
when the real deal unfolds overseas.
So that is part of the training
and it's fairly intense.
I mean there were pyrotechnics.
They had dust hit so it looked
like right rifle fire was
hitting the ground and [inaudible]
and all the while the instructors
were sort of yelling and adding
to the stress in that sort of
boot camp Marine instructor way.
So, it was not a pleasant day
for those young men and women
but hopefully helpful for
them in the long-term.
>> Tim Smith: So I'll ask one more
question and then we'll turn it
over to questions from the audience.
But I guess the highest
achievement in the science
of war would be making
war not lethal.
Is there any chance
of that happening?
>> Mary Roach: Well, if it's
all, if it's all, well not lethal
to both sides or to one side?
>> Tim Smith: Honest, I guess
both, I guess if it's not lethal
to one side maybe it's
not lethal to the other.
>> Mary Roach: Well then
it's called diplomacy.
>> Tim Smith: Well that's
true too, good point.
>> Mary Roach: And I'm all for that.
Yeah, I mean there's a lot of,
you know of course moving towards
using drones in the place of boots
on the ground which
is a policy issue.
I don't really write about that.
>> Tim Smith: Right.
>> Mary Roach: But certainly
that seems to be the direction
that things are going, yeah.
>> Tim Smith: So, let's
turn it over to you.
We microphones to my right and to my
left, and if you have any questions
about this book or any of her
previous books, get up and ask.
I think we've got about
ten minutes left or so.
Yes mam?
>> Unidentified Speaker
1: Hi, I'm a big fan.
You tend to write a
lot about subjects
that people tend to
be squeamish about.
Do you have any techniques for
getting people to talk about these
in ways that they're
more comfortable?
>> Mary Roach: By that you mean
the people that I'm interviewing,
the researchers or scientists?
>> Unidentified Speaker 1: Yeah.
>> Mary Roach: Yeah, yeah they are.
They tend to be squeamish
topics but if say you're someone
who researches human sexual
response or in women in particular,
having a conversation about the
clitoris or about the amount
of blood in the vaginal walls,
that's just your day-to-day
that's not,
so they're not at all squeamish.
And for them it's like having
a conversation about you know,
tire rotation or something,
it's not.
There's no charge to the topic,
it's actually very easy to step in
and have a conversation with
someone about their work
because for them it's
just their job.
So I don't really have
any techniques other
than just being very
straightforward with them.
Yeah?
>> Unidentified Speaker
2: Hi, I was interested,
during your research did you go
out to Forest Glen to the Museum
of Military Medicine to
study any of the information
that they have out there?
And if so, what was your impression?
>> Mary Roach: I did not.
I, years ago went to the AFIP museum
where they have like the collection
of bones and gunshot
injuries and things like that.
I don't know if that is, that's.
I know that AFIP museum moved.
I don't know if that's
where it moved.
Is that separate?
>> Unidentified Speaker 2:
That was at Walter Reed,
that's where it moved out to.
>> Mary Roach: Yes.
>> Unidentified Speaker 2:
It's in a brand new building.
>> Mary Roach: I haven't been
and I would love to, yeah.
>> Tim Smith: Yes?
>> Unidentified Speaker 3: Hi.
>> Mary Roach: Hi.
>> Unidentified Speaker 3: I
love that you take one tiny topic
and you go ten miles deep
with it or 100 miles deep.
Do you find that there's one core
message in all of your books?
What's the one story
you're always telling?
>> Mary Roach: If there's
one core message,
well there are a couple
of core, one is.
I mean I'm fascinated by
the human body in extreme
and unusual situations and to me you
know I used to in my 20s do a lot
of overseas, just travel.
I was just always looking
to go to far-flung
and the more remote the better
and at a certain point I realized
the human body is a foreign planet
and it's so interesting to
explore and I never get tired of it
and I still have so much to learn.
So, and I enjoy sort of sharing
the learning with my readers so.
And I guess the other core is
scientists are so smart, fun,
cool and interesting and
I you know I guess I'm,
so I probably should have
been one but so being able
to just you know knock on these
doors and step into these worlds
and find out what people are doing
and just the commitment and passion
that they have for their work
is endlessly inspiring so over
and over that's what I encounter.
Yeah?
>> Tim Smith: Over here.
>> Unidentified Speaker 4: Hi.
>> Mary Roach: Hi.
>> Unidentified Speaker
4: I have two thoughts.
I want to try to tie them together
because they're kind of related.
So you mentioned when we first sat
down Roachable territory,
I think you said.
So, have you come across anything
that you find is not
Roachable territory
or maybe something you're
not willing to talk about?
And kind of related, I know a
lot of your books obviously are
about the human experience but you
go into animal stuff and for me,
that's hard for me to read
personally so I've had to kind
of like skip over some of that.
Is there anything you
won't talk about?
>> Mary Roach: Oh yes, well
I would say 90 some percent
of science isn't particularly
Roachable because it's gone
into the microscopic,
you know it's molecular.
It's genomic.
It's not bodies on a slab which is
really my terrain and so I'm really.
It's a very small sliver
of science in a way.
I'm kind of a gateway
drug to science and I,
which a role that I love.
I love when young people read the
book, get excited about science
and think I want to do science
and then of course there they are
in molecular biology
going damn you Mary Roach.
This is hard [laughter].
But fortunately they keep going
and then they go to medical school
and they become researchers
or doctors so.
But have I, well yes I
agree with you the animal,
the animal studies, I wouldn't.
I mean I, that is an
interesting part of science.
I know a friend of mine is an
author, Rebecca [inaudible]
who wrote that book "The Immortal
Life of Henrietta [inaudible]".
She's working on a
book right now about.
Oh man, I wasn't supposed
to reveal that.
I'm sorry [inaudible] but it
has to do, because she used
to be a veterinary technician
so it's about that whole world
and you know it makes
sense for her to do that.
I would be uncomfortable
on a lot of levels.
Also my tone I don't think
is appropriate and I,
so that yes I agree with you.
And the segments that you've
skipped, the little bit.
Those are when people like.
>> Unidentified Speaker
4: I kind of glanced over.
>> Mary Roach: So yeah,
yeah, you skimmed them.
Yeah, people will write to me and
share that, not in an angry way
but say I had trouble with that.
So, yeah you won't probably see
me doing that as a topic but.
>> Unidentified Speaker 4: Thanks.
>> Tim Smith: To the left, sir?
>> Unidentified Speaker 5:
Yes, on a related topic,
what happens to those maggots
after they've been used
to clean the wound?
And the same question
goes for leeches?
>> Mary Roach: Yeah, oh
yes after they're removed
from the wound they go to a
maggot retirement community
where they're cared for, lavished
with lots of lovely dead [laughter].
Yeah, I don't know if they're
taken outdoors to go pupate.
Hopefully, hopefully they are
and I think having the man
who runs Medical Maggots has such
a. You know after the book came
out he sent me this box with a
little tube with alcohol and a bunch
of little maggots in there as a
gift for me, a little [inaudible].
He has a. I like to think that they
are set free to become flies so
but I'm not entirely
sure that that's true.
>> Tim Smith: So we've got time for
one more question and it will be.
>> Unidentified Speaker 6:
Okay, the pressure's on, hello.
>> Mary Roach: Hi.
>> Unidentified Speaker
6: So my question is
of all the scientists
you've read about,
of all the scientists you've
met, who are a few who stand
out to you as like unsung heroes?
>> Mary Roach: Oh, well just
because we happen to be on maggots,
George Peck the maggot guy, trying
to get the folks at Walter Reed
to say, you know to see the value
of this because there are a lot
of problems with infection.
And just, you know this is a
man who had me into his home
and he said I've raised a clutch
of maggots for you so you can.
And he came in and this
was at the dinner table,
he had this little cut glass bowl
and I thought it was chocolate
pudding but it was raw liver
and there were these maggots
and he said look at them.
Look at them, those mandibles
can do what no surgeon can
and he had this passion for maggots
and I just love people like that.
I mean just anyway George Peck comes
to mind but there would be dozens
of them, not maggots,
scientists, scientists that I love.
>> Unidentified Speaker
6: Thank you.
>> Tim Smith: Mary,
this was delightful,
thank you so much for
taking the time.
>> Mary Roach: Thank
you so much, thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov